but i want to encourage you that every
minute you're wasting scrolling on a
platform could be a minute that you
could be figuring out your next video
idea creating your next title getting uh
the settings right on your camera every
single time you're picking up your phone
to spend time on social media quote
unquote researching is time that you're
not actually spending doing what is the
income producing activity
tell me if you can relate to this you
are overwhelmed you're overworked and
you're just plain tired well if that's
you and your content creator or
entrepreneur today's episode is going to
be right up your alley as i'm going to
be sharing with you 15 of my
productivity hacks to help you get more
done in less time and be able to be
creating the content that you want to
create my name is heather torres and i
am your host of the think media podcast
welcome to our show here on the think
media podcast channel if you're watching
live on youtube right now i want to
welcome you for being a part of what
we're doing make sure you hit that
subscribe button and if you're brand new
to the podcast we post a new episode
every single tuesday so if you are
listening make sure you subscribe
wherever you like to consume this
content on this show we bring a new
webclass to you every single week so you
can watch our free on-demand class right
now by going to
tubemasterclass.com i'm sharing with you
how to get to your first 1000
subscribers and earn your first 1 000
and beyond and how to make your youtube
plan for this year so make sure you head
over to
tubemasterclass.com if you want to see
that free on demand class i want to be
sharing with you 15 of my time saving
productivity hacks um as a content
creator these are just different things
that over the last decade i have just
put into practice and i wanted to share
them with you today number one i want
you to set a timer and stick to it work
consistently until that alarm goes off
and then be ready to stop until the next
time this is a great hack if you are
trying to get as much done as you can in
a short amount of time or really any
amount of time and this to me is the
antidote to multitasking multitasking is
actually horrible so i want you to be
setting a timer and doing the activity
that you've calendar blocked in that
time and make it a game make it fun see
if you can get that edit done in 60
minutes see if you can get your filming
done in 90 minutes whatever that looks
like set a timer and stick to it number
two keep a running list of video ideas
as a content creator it's really wise
that as you're out in the world as
people are asking you questions that you
just have a running list of those video
ideas i like to use bullets when i'm
also thinking of those video ideas of at
the time if i've got the idea what are
three things or five things i could talk
about in that video so just keep a
running list of those ideas so when you
sit down to write your script you
actually have something in front of you
and you're not just staring at a blank
piece of paper number three i want you
to remember that it's one video one idea
and we should just answer specific
questions do product reviews do
influence surfing but remembering that
every single video is just one idea so a
time-saving hack to this is that rather
than trying to shove everything into one
video think about one video one video
idea
number four take the time to write your
script and rehearse it before you press
record almost every single one of my
videos that i do now i actually rehearse
it almost all the way through in front
of a mirror or in front of the camera so
that i know what i'm going to be saying
if i need to be delivering precise
content
i think it's really important that you
write a script and we have different
script templates for you here at think
media i'll make sure to list our video
down below in the description as well as
in the show notes for you but be writing
out your script don't just hit record
and try and figure it out i'm even
reading off of a script right now during
this podcast to be able to know exactly
what i want to say and i've actually
read all these prior to this podcast so
i rehearsed it beforehand
number five keep your workspace simple
and tidy nothing is worse than going to
film a video and realizing that there's
a laundry pile your desk is messy
there's dishes in your sink whatever
that looks like keep your space nice and
tidy i think it's really great when you
go to make content just freshen it up
just keep it nice and tidy it helps to
clear your mind and clear the workspace
number six
choose a simple video wardrobe that you
can cycle through easily this is a time
saving tip especially for all of my
content creators who need to look good
right
that to me is something where i just
want to make sure that i am being a good
representation of the style that i want
on camera but i actually have a wardrobe
in my closet that has about 10 different
shirts a couple jackets now i've got
some sweatshirts thrown into there but i
just rotate through those all the time
so just keep a simple wardrobe so you're
not wasting time trying to think about
what you're going to wear on camera
number seven
if you're using music in your videos
pick a series of songs that feel on
brand for you and just use those songs
it's okay if you're repeating music over
and over in your video it can help to
brand your video um and and there could
just be a simplicity to what you're
doing and it can help save time i know
that as a content creator as you're
searching for the right song that's an
air quote the right song the right sound
for it you could be spending so much
time wasted doing that so maybe just
schedule some time to go into say
epidemic music and go through uh the
different songs that you like you can
favorite them you can create a list and
then you can just go back and use that
same music number eight be willing to
upgrade your equipment you can actually
save more time and money when you're
using the right gear i think one of the
easiest things that i've been able to do
is have my entire desk ready to go to
film videos at any time i literally just
sit down click it on turn on my lights
and it's ready to go and i had to invest
in that equipment you know i wanted to
to make this a part of what i'm doing as
my career and so i was willing to invest
to have it set up so that it's there all
the time so be willing to upgrade your
equipment is a productivity and time
saving hack
number nine batch your videos by making
two at a time this saves you time
because if you're gonna set everything
up if you're gonna put your makeup on if
you're gonna get ready for it you might
as well film two videos rather than one
and actually i'm practicing what i
preach right now i'm sitting down making
this podcast but literally five minutes
ago i filmed the podcast that you
listened to last week i just changed my
shirt put a hat on for this one and i'm
filming two videos instead of one video
the lights are going on the camera's
going on i'm gonna save time by filming
these two because i'm already in a
filming state so always film more than
one video if you can number 10 be sure
to upload all your raw video footage to
a second hard drive or a space in your
computer that is organized
as you start creating more and more
content this can bog you down if you
need to go back and look for b-roll if
you are just uploading random content
and not naming your files if you aren't
backing up your uh your actual footage
you can run into having to refilm things
because the hard drive crashed or
something happened to the computer you
want to make sure that you are clean and
organized when you go into it this is a
huge time saving tip for content
creators let me know if you've had files
on your computer that say like
sb1695 and it's like in a folder and
then everything's just kind of labeled
and it doesn't have any organization to
it
label it with the actual file name of
the video that you're doing and then as
you're putting the the photos or the
videos inside of there label those as
well so you can go back and you know
what you're doing
number eleven set aside one day to shoot
thumbnail photos that you can use for
future videos it was interesting sean
and i were just talking that the last
time we did a photo shoot for our
thumbnails was about nine months ago we
haven't we've used the same exact
thumbnail images for the last nine
months because we set aside one day to
take a bunch of photos so that we're not
having to take photos every single time
we're making a video number 12
hire an editor to edit your videos or a
graphic designer to create your
thumbnails this is a huge productivity
tip that if you are someone who's
already in business already making a
profit i want to encourage you to bring
someone on your team you can get an
editor from vid chops from fiverr from
upworks from inside of our think media
community with other people who are
content creators and actual editors uh i
want to recommend that if you're not
geeking out about the editing process if
it's not your your thing that you love
to do then hire that out because you can
actually create more content in that
time that you would have been learning
editing editing your videos doing all of
those extra things
you can't hire out you but you can hire
out everything else around you that'll
save you a lot of time number 13 set
deadlines for uploading your videos and
hold yourself to it
this is something i had to grow in when
i was growing my homeschooling channel i
would set a deadline and i pushed the
deadline i'd set a deadline and i pushed
a deadline and once i actually just
committed to no i'm making this video
and it's going out on thursday come hell
or high water it's gonna happen that's
when i was able to reverse engineer
actually making that happen so i want
you to commit to yourself to when are
you going to upload the video when does
it go live because if you don't set that
time it's going to sit on your computer
it's going to be something you dabble
with on the weekend it's not going to be
something that you're actually putting
time and energy into and when you set
that goal you can actually save yourself
more time because you're not just
dabbling you're dominating on youtube
number 14 don't reinvent the wheel this
is a time-saving hack for you right here
there are great websites out there uh
like unsplash.com that can create
professional looking photos or things
like project management software like
trello and click up that can help you
track so here's why i put this on the
list because i see content creators
wasting so much time trying to make
everything look pretty or trying to
organize everything and they're just
spinning their wheels over and over
again and if there's already great
templates out there like you can right
now look up trello templates for content
creators and you can get an actual
template that you don't have to build
you can go to unsplash.com and look up
if maybe you have a gardening channel
tomatoes and there's beautiful photos of
tomatoes there are so many ways that you
could be saving time by utilizing what's
already been created
i think another place that i love to go
is actually etsy i went to etsy and i
wanted to figure out a script that
looked pretty and i went to etsy and i
found a script it looked pretty and so
there's so many different places where
people have already spent the time to
create the thing to
take the picture to get the b-roll that
you could just be utilizing and saving
your time and then last number 15
take a fast from social media and other
things like youtube you want to save
more time i want you to pull out your
phone and look at how much time you are
spending on social media i know sounds
like your mom telling you what you can't
do but i want to encourage you that
every minute you're wasting scrolling on
a platform could be a minute that you
could be figuring out your next video
idea creating your next title getting uh
the settings right on your camera
figuring out the live stream you want to
do setting up your uh your new course
getting your podcast launched every
single time you're picking up your phone
to spend time on social media quote
unquote researching is time that you're
not actually spending doing what is the
income producing activity
well we just went through 15 of my time
saving productivity hacks let me know
which one you liked down in the comment
section below on youtube i'd love to
know if you have extras to add to it
there's one thing i love about the think
media community it's how you contribute
to the conversation so down in the
comments below if you have a time saving
hack productivity hack as a content
creator that you've utilized let me know
i'd love to see that and if you are
someone who likes to listen on
apple podcast i want to thank you for
being a part of what we're doing here at
think media
every single week i love to read
different reviews and this one was wild
i loved this one uh this is from d
witters he said bruh what if explanation
mark question mark exclamation mark
question mark what if you killed are you
all your excuses let's go and use all
the emojis i love emojis so if you leave
a review with an emoji you light up my
world thank you
but thank you so much for being a part
of what we're doing here at think media
thank you for the five stars that you
left on that review it means the world
to me that you are part of our community
here that you are listening and that you
are killing the excuses and going all in
on youtube we have so much great content
coming for you uh in this next season
we've got a podcast appearances from
garyvee patrickbetdavid chalene johnson
omar altacory so many amazing
entrepreneurs who are winning with
content right now i cannot wait for you
to hear that upcoming content thank you
for being a part of what we're doing and
we'll catch you in the next episode bye
[Music]